revient sur l'histoire du pont
tunnel.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le projet a été annoncé
en 1962 par le gouvernement
du Québec et les travaux ont
commencé en juillet 1963 avec
nique révolutionnaire
du concepteur québécois
Armand Couture.
Au lieu de creuser sous le lit
du fleuve, sept caissons
en béton précontraint ont été
coulés au bord du fleuve en cale
sèche, puis transportés par
flottage jusqu'à une tranchée
creusée au fond du St-Laurent,
tout un exploit.
L'étanchéité des caissons
a été rendue possible grâce
une couche d'enduit bitumineux
et de fire.
Ces caissons ont la taille
d'un terrain de football chacun.
Ils ont ensuite été immergésé is
et assemblés, entre autres,
grâce au travail exceptionnel
de plongeurs.
Autre réalisation :
la construction deruction derucs
de ventilation pour permettre
l'évacuation du monoxide
nne et l'entrée d'air
frais. Et histoire de réduire
les coûts, il est décidé
unnel, long de près
d'un kilomètre et demi, reliera
Montréal à l'île Charron.
Un pont en béton devra donc
être construit pour relier l'île
à la rive sud du St-laurent.
Pour réaliser les travaux
de préparation, le quartier
de Longue-Pointe et son église
à l'extrémité est de l'île
ont été rasés et plus
de 300 familles ont été
expropriées.
Au fil des années
des rénovations importantesieu.,
la dalle du pont de l'île
Charron a été refaite
et une voie de circulation
a été ajoutée en direction sud.
L'accident de circulation
le plus grave est survenu
en 1985. Un camion poids lourd
a embouti un véhicule provoq
un incendie. Le tunnel a alors
été fermé pendant un mois
pour réparer les dégâts.
La construction du pont-tunnel
a coûté 75 millions de dollars
payée en grande pa
par le gouvernement fédéral.
Cet ouvrage constitue
l'un des plus gran
en béton précontraint au monde.
Le pont-tunnel est nommé
en l'honyte
La Fontaine qui a été premier
ministre du Canada-Est
de 1842 l était
originaire de Boucherville.
Il a été inauguré par le premier
ministrenhson,
le chef de l'opposition Jean
Lesage et le maire de Montréal,
1 mars 1967.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Mon